l'an dernier cela nous l'a rappelé
encore tout récemment 82% du de la
richesse économique a été captées par 1%
de la population et cette proportion
augmente chaque année et donc je pense
qu'il ya une certaine inquiétude de la
part des orthodoxes ce qu'il ya quand
même quelque chose qui ne va pas et donc
on a entendu mario draghi a appelé à une
plus juste répartition des fruits de la
croissance
ils le fmi aussi ce qui était arrivé
également alors on est encore très loin
du compte et les faucons et a alerté de
wolverine chase sont toujours à l'affût
mais volkan cheveux bleus n'est plus
ministre des finances allemand et donc
exemple que la tête du bundestag et donc
je pense que le contexte pourrait se
prêter à un meilleur équilibre dans la
politique économique